normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government here's
a story from Politico fresh Revelations
contradict Joe Biden's sweeping denials
on Hunter the corporate press is coming
out against Joe Biden we know what's
going to happen replace Donald Trump is
going to come out and say that Taco Bell
is too expensive and Big Max are 18
bucks and then the Democrats are going
to get rid of Joe Biden and this is how
they do it yep do you think that they're
going to do you think that there's going
to be like a terrorist attack here in
the United States within the next 12
months yes it'll be like Hamas related
or Hamas inspired as an excuse to both
get us into World War III and get Joe
Biden out for his border policy so they
can just replace him at the last second
think based on the reporting we've seen
from a very simple uh a very simple
assessment if you trust the the
government which I don't know why you
would but assuming you did they're
telling you that there is a a risk of of
Terror happening in in in in this next
year if you are a I don't know
pessimistic Politico you're probably
like oh yeah I mean The Border's been
ripped to shreds they're capturing
people in the ter uh the terror watch
list down there so yes we're at Great
risk the probability is decent now as
for if it connects to Joe Biden in World
War III I don't know about that but I do
not see Joe Biden being the nominee for
the Democratic party how they get rid of
get out yeah this is not the best way to
do it accusing the Dem Joe Biden of
corruption that's going to lead to a
trump Victory even if you bring in
Newsome but if Joe Biden had some kind
of like medical episode and Gavin
Newsome runs on a stage and saves his
life now Gavin Newsome is the front
runner and that's a clean exit for Joe
Biden I think the clean IIT is ideal for
both parties this was Mutual the fact
that it's so much so many Hunter
Revelations makes me think that the
Biden Camp is resisting and they're
going to go Kicking and Screaming so
they have to destroy him because he
won't go quietly and so they're saying
would be to Pardon him for everything
though then they would stop
investigating because it would be moot
no the issue is the Deep State goes to I
I guess the theory is the Deep state
would go to Joe Biden and say hey we'd
like you to bow out not run for second
term and we're going to bring in Newsome
and Joe Biden says no I can do it man
come on I'm I'm I'm not I'm good for it
and they're like Joe we're telling you
we're not going to let you do this and
he goes you can't stop me and so they're
like we're going to we're going to have
to forcefully this guy remov that's how
I felt the first couple years that they
were asking him like do you think you're
going to run and he was like yeah yeah
for sure and then Karin jerre or whoever
was in maybe jump St be like oh they're
talking about it they're thinking about
it like there was obviously some sort of
uh disagreement internally and yet Biden
is still announced you know via video
that he was going to run again and
that's when you saw an increase in the
pressure on H Biden I mean the fact that
the mainstream media is now willing to
talk about it is like this very bitter
pill because ultimately it means they
don't actually care about this at all
they care about something else and we'll
find out about it in six months I think
he's going to exit the presidential race
like he exited Afghanistan in a
humiliating surrender he will have to
Pardon his kid first that'll be like the
sign that you know that it's over is
when you hear that Hunter's getting
pardoned and then like in a week you're
going to hear that he's not I don't
think he I mean he's 100,000 years old
anyways but he couldn't run again if he
pardoned his own kid he was born like 3
years after the air conditioning was
invented for the automobile there was
some yeah there was some study there was
like he was born closer to the Civil I
can't remember what it was I don't want
to misquote it but closer to the Civil
War war than today he was old enough to
he was potty trained by the time Hitler
died so he's old enough to remember when
Hitler was still on the radio was born
in 42 wow yeah November 20th hey his
birthday's coming up I mean and that I I
feel like we should be honest obviously
Trump is is older too but he doesn't
slur and Shuffle the way Joe Biden does
yeah it's cular age he's way younger
yeah and I think that's I mean this is
it's not true anymore it was true the
year a couple years ago okay cuz he was
born 77 years after the end of the Civil
War so when he was 76 he was born closer
oh wait no no no no it's actually true
now I always be true right I mean it
would always be true right once it
becomes true right so no no I was wrong
no it is true
now wow it was 77 years from the Civil
War and he's what is he 708 78 yeah oh
no he took off took office at the age of
78 yeah right so that yeah you were
right I was wrong no it is true now he
he he was born closer to the Civil War
than to today right than like from his
birth I mean this is just how time works
but then to be like and this is the guy
leading our country this is the guy who
can't remember anything definitely be a
like if you have to be at least 35 you
should have to be not over 65 it was
honestly one of Mitt Romney's best
political moments when he announced he
was going to retire rather continue to
see terms cuz he was like if I run again
I will be in my 80s and that's too old
and you know that that's not a terrible
Point again I'm not saying that Trump
shouldn't run and not saying that
everyone who's in their 80 is in the
position Joe Biden is in but we can't
say that we're like this young spry
country there was a reason that JFK had
such an influence on politics right that
he was young he had these kids a
beautiful wife whatever else well Trump
is spry well and this was one of the
appeals for santis in the beginning
people were comparing him you know to
this young he's got young children
whatever else got a young wife there was
sort of this idea that it was sort of a
brush of FR there this was before I
think Trump announced obviously there's
more contention now I'm not trying to
weigh on on that got him on his heels
but then Biden ha but then uh uh not
Biden then Des santis showed up to
school wearing high heels and everyone
went hey look new kids wearing high
heels and he went shut up no I'm not
bring this up I was thinking about this
before the show so um Ren he's in Iowa
right now and he's doing this you know
uh rally with Kim Reynolds and there's a
picture of him so it's Casey Rhonda Sanz
and then the governor of Iowa and her
husband and Casey Anthony is wearing
sneakers and I then tried to pull a
photo of her in heels and they are
weirdly always the same height diff
difference even when she's in heels and
in sneakers there's a there's a meme
photo showing Ronda santis walking on
the beach Barefoot with his wife and
he's got the same height Advantage then
there's a photo of her wearing high
heels and he has the same height
Advantage it doesn't make sense like I
just use some science toic get out there
was like a moment I was sitting in my
office comparing pictures of them in
different
shoes this was an easy catch either she
needs to always be in heels we maintain
this height difference or she can never
wear sneak I don't think the problem is
that he's short though like I think he
should have just leaned into it like hey
you know statistics show that if you
perceived is short it's a disadvantage
so I just try to you know fit the bill
like debate on podiums there someone
super chatted that when Patrick Bet
David questioned him on the on the high
heels and said how how tall are you he
should have went well I identify as 6'2
and then everyone would have laughed and
that would have been the smooth yeah
that's good ide instead he was like what
are you talking about I'm not wearing
high heels it just boots a butt off the
wreck like every other normal person
does
I am human yeah he was he even said he
he hadn't seen the meme which is like yo
been out for a week or his or his team
was too scared to show him what did he
say it's no time for foot fetishes is
that he got yeah some interviewer he
lost the foot
boat that's a very controversial opinion
to take man there's a bunch of guys on
wik feet being like Ron's lost my vote
this is it says Casey de santis is 55 or
5'9 depending on the source wow maybe
she should come on the show because I'm
59 so we this is why he this is why he
won't come on the show because we're
going to be like take the boots off we
we we have a fine carpet household here
literally I'm wearing socks right now
just so you know I don't have shoes on
we should we should Implement you don't
need to hold your feet up e but I
already did it no we just have
toar because our carpets uh you know we
we they get cleaned every week and uh
but to preserve the longevity no shoes
policy so Ron please come on the show
and no shoes I mean I would love it
would be funny if he took his shoes off
and his feet are just shaped like that
like Big Blocks like it's he just has he
has really thick heels figure did you at
every point that would be a really funny
bit actually he takes the boots off and
his feet are just gigantic triangles
were you supporting him at any way
before at any point I always thought
that he was a good Governor but I knew
that I was going to vote for Trump as
soon as they started Prosecuting him so
I was sort of somebody that hadn't made
a decision yet but as soon as they
really started coming down with the
prosecutions it's like I'm going to vote
for the guy that they hate most what do
you think about V I like V I had him on
my podcast
um he's obviously been on infow Wars
recently with Alex I think that V is a
very bright very honest guy that is
positioning himself for some other
reason than to be president I think he
wants to be in second everybody in the
Republican side wants to be in second
place because if Trump gets de balloted
then it's like there's got to be
somebody else right and so I think that
was kind of the original thing but what
he really seems to be pulling for for me
is a campaign of awareness but also he
could be easily put in some sort of a
cabinet position after and he's been
very smart in that he's been the only
candidate on the right who hasn't come
out and criticized Trump directly and
you never want to attack a stronger
enemy head on I think the reason Dan
santis is losing so badly is because his
campaign strategy was to attack a
stronger enemy head-on just come after
Trump seething right away it was very
stupid V has never once insulted Trump
when I asked him he said that he thought
Trump was a great president he just
thinks it's time for somebody else just
very vanilla and that's why you never
see Trump bashing V but he'll bash all
the other candidates but not V because
V's never been a dick to him yeah yeah
that's a good point that's very sunzo MH
yeah it seems like despite what V is
saying he's he's going for the for the
VP or the next or something yeah he be a
great VP he would be because he's a I
mean vake is is as sharp as they come i'
I've watched I watch a bunch of his
Clips on on Instagram and Twitter when
he does interviews and I'm just like man
well he he had a brilliant strategy he
did like three podcasts a day for six
months so he comes off sounding so
polished like Obama did but Obama got
there because of the focus groups V get
got there because he's answered the same
questions 1,700 times cuz he's been done
so many appearances so he's just got the
right answer for everything and he's
high IQ sharp guy I don't think I know
he made money from some Soros fund or
whatever at one point I know he's
invested in big farm at one point but I
don't think he sold out to them I don't
I don't believe I don't care I don't
care if someone does right if if if you
meet like if David hog tomorrow came out
and said in tears that he's looking at
these statistics and he and he can't
believe how wrong he was and he wants to
dedicate his time to fighting for gun
rights would people be like no no some
people would but I'd be like this is
fantastic a guy with a million now all
so if V did do things you don't like but
now he's saying all the right things
keep encouraging to say he WF and one
because they didn't they make him a
young Global leader he's like I never
gave you my approval for that and that's
the thing like you if David hog came out
and was like I'm actually for gun rights
now I would say please show me the gun
you have recently purchased and so I can
believe you are actually committed to
this cause I mean there is one thing to
say I've changed my mind there's nothing
to actually prove and consistently
behave as though you have changed your
mind I would go buy a gun with David hog
that' be a good do love that as a uh as
content on YouTube I feel like that
would be really interesting who would
you go buy a gun or not YouTube X or
whatever we're into now I'd probably if
somebody wanted to go buy a gun and I
was thinking about buying a gun I'd
probably do it with them if they wanted
to yeah Greta yeah for sure we could
talk about gun rights and how they're
awesome the second amendment's legit it
is quite indeed oh speaking of Second
Amendment the infringe documentary is
officially up tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. 12
hours laen southern yeah and we'll be
doing a big old ad campaign promoting it
so uh let me just say to all of you
listening when you go to timcast and you
become a member what do we do we uh uh
commission Lauren Southern and John dto
is I'm I pronouncing his name right to
so I'm like I don't know as a French D
and uh they do excellent work and that
was a very expensive uh a very expensive
project with all the travel and all the
people and all the scheduling and uh
then we're also going to be dumping
large large amounts of money into
marketing that documentary all over the
place and it is a documentary explaining
the importance I I shouldn't put it that
way but it's about gun rights it's
called infring and explains the purpose
and the point it talks a lot about the
issue of guns from a very I would say
proun perspective I saw the trailer is
the trailers public at this point I
think there there's a couple clips from
it already up on youtube.com/ timcast as
well as some trailers and then we've got
uh three different short trailers coming
up I like the way they framed it because
it they really highlighted the dangers
of like mass shootings and gun violence
and then it sounds like then they start
to talk about why it's important to
protect your rights and defend yourself
from that stuff it's really simple
actually a centralized security
apparatus does not work the idea that
you can give all of your security to one
organization in one location is an
absurdity eight at the very least argue
8020 right that 20% of the security is
handled by the individual and 80% by the
apparatus I'm not even saying that I'm
just saying at minimum the idea that
only police will have guns means
criminals will have guns because clearly
they're in violation of the law and the
saying goes when seconds matter police
are minutes away right and this is why
we experience more uh this is why the
study showed that in uh gunfree zones
people are less likely to stop a mass
shooter and everywhere else excluding
gunfree zones 51% of shootings were
stopped by a good a person La legally a
lot of mass shooter shootings happen in
gun in gunfree zones like they happen in
places like schools and I had a dream
last night that we meet a group and I
went to protect these people people and
we got there and they were like okay
someone's got to stay to protect the
kids the children and I was like okay
I'll do it so I stayed there but all I
had was a knife and I was just there
with the kids and then this guy came and
he had a shotgun it was like one of
those pump action automatic
semi-automatic shotguns and I was like
trying to to dodge him around the the
couch and I ran around the edge and he
just shot me in the face I was like damn
it and then I was still alive in the
dream and I was like I need a gun I
cannot I cannot defend myself and these
kids without one I heard you can't die
in dreams I didn't yeah I don't I've
never really died true I think you wake
no I've died in dreams before and just
been dead but like it just the dream
keeps going in a different way I I i'
I've had tons of Dreams where I've died
you die and you're just laying there and
like everybody's hanging out no no like
I had a dream where there was a nuclear
explosion and then everyone died and
then all of a sudden I was still in my
dream doing something else like I it's
like oh wow we all died in nuclear
explosion but we're still just like in a
different building now I don't know how
did you know that you died so I had a
dream where we were in a car and there
was like we saw like an ICB I'm coming
like ah and then like a nuke went off
and then I was it was like it was like a
nightmare it was like a scary feeling
and then there's like a wall of like
white light and then all of a sudden
it's just me and other people were in a
room and we're like wow I can't believe
we all died in that nuclear explosion
and then just like you were in the lobby
of like heaven something like that I
don't know maybe but in dreams things
don't make sense and you don't realize
things are happening so it's just like
it carried on and then I woke up like
whoa that was a crazy dream I love that
relief when you get killed in your dream
and you're like oh I'm not really dead
this is awesome Dre so Ian's died
I have this dream all the time where I
need to shoot somebody and I don't have
the strength to pull the trigger you
ever had that dream you're yeah in my
dream I couldn't bring myself to stab
the guy because I didn't want to get
blood all over the place I'm like what
is
wrong that's not it it's the idea called
punching in a dream yeah you can't exert
Force because of it's something to do
with the chemical that paralyzes your
body so you move really slow you can't
run properly and also something about
because of because of the way like your
brain works in dreams you can't read
either and so so uh when it comes to
lucid dreaming one of the techniques is
to try and read so there's a bunch of
things you can do but you can uh uh if
you want to read about one of them is
when you read something it's gibberish
you should you should realize you're
dreaming there's a bunch there's a bunch
of other other tricks too Biden's
inaugural speech I always notice if
you're ever in a dream and you can't get
out and you want to get out close your
eyes really tight tight until you can
feel it and as soon as you feel it when
you open them you'll be awake because
it's that feeling that wakes you up I
mean body's different when I usually
want to wake up I just wake up I don't
know it's like excellent self discipline
yeah I just wake up I'm like oh wow I
was having a bad dream I've had dreams
where I think I have woken up and so I
can picture my room and stuff like that
but I am actually still asleep and I
think this is often because I have to
set up a lot of alarm so you're sort of
waking up and you're immediately falling
back to sleep the dream where you like
get up and get take a shower and get
dressed and you're like on your way to
work and then all a sudden you wake up I
got to do it all again turn out none of
that is real it's very frustrating I do
think it's funny that nightmare are
depicted in media as like being attacked
by monsters or like chased by a killer
when in reality nightmares are like you
have a dream that you miss you're late
for work yeah you know it's like my
nightmares are like I woke up at 8:30
and I'm like oh crap and I'm like trying
to get dressed real fast and I'm like
I'm anxiety like I got to get up there I
got to record oh man and then I wake up
and at 7:00 and I'm
like Brin just like feeling stressed out
let's see what happens I used to have
this dream that I uh would get to the
last day or like exams when I was in
college and realized that I had
forgotten about a class I had signed up
for for the entire semester I had that
dream before it was extrem I always
found it not graduating dream it's not
even that I wouldn't graduate it's just
like suddenly you realized you were
supposed to be either you would fail
this class because you had to go take
the exam but actually you had never
taken the class and you didn't realize
you had funny I had that dream like
twice a year I thought I was the only
one I would get the one where uh I would
be on stage but for the play that I
never rehearsed for like I got all these
lines and I don't know any of them
literally it's the most like let 10,000
people watching or whatever 5,000 people
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net